rien semble aussi régulièrement on
découvre des sélections livres pour nos
enfants à voir ou à revoir sur les
réseaux sociaux et les plateformes
numériques tiphaine cypher en raison des
mesures sanitaires on se voit par écran
interposé mais même si nous sommes
toujours confiné dans ces moments là on
s'aperçoit que la nature ça peut que
nous faire du bien on en manque
notamment si on vire vire alors voulu
nous avait amené une sélection de livres
résolument écologistes on va prendre
l'air j'ai l'impression avec go typhaine
oui oui on va parler de nature et on va
parler d'enfants qui s'investissent pour
soigner la planète comme notre premier
petit héros qui s'appelle barnabé et lui
son idée donc c'est soigner la planète
comme le titre de ce livre de gilles
bizouerne et béatrix rodrigues est
publié chez didier jeunesse et c'est à
partir de 4 ans alors figurez-vous que
barnabé le petit blaireau entend à la
radio
et bien que la planète est malade alors
il se dit je vais la soigner il part en
forêt retrouver ses amis et monte une
expédition pour soigner la planète alors
ils ne savent pas très bien comment
faire mais ils vont faire de petits
gestes pour essayer de remédier et de
soigner les symptômes
alors c'est un album que j'ai beaucoup
aimée parce que les dessins sont très
doux
l histoire est très simple donc
accessible dès 4 ans et scelle la morale
est très jolie puisqu'elle permet de
dire aux enfants que quel que soit leur
âge ils peuvent s'investir et faire de
petits gestes pour l'environnement et
pour les plus grands
vous avez un roman alors on va dire sur
la même thématique évidemment c'est une
petite fille par équipes qui rêvent de
devenir une abeille c'est ça oui ça elle
s'appelle pivoines c'est très joli je ne
sais pas si vous en connaissez
et c'est l'héroïne de ce roman la
dernière abeille de brain mind ibl
publié chez ayant alors c'est un roman
assez sombre des parents puisque figurez
vous que dans ce roman les enfants
doivent polliniser toutes les fleurs à
la main puisque les abeilles ont disparu
mais puis whannell elle adore en fait
vivre dans sa ferme collective ou la vie
rude puisque elle vit au milieu de la
nature et qu'elle s'estime assez
chanceuse par rapport aux aux enfants de
la ville où la misère est assez
prégnante
alors c'est un très joli roman puisque
elle valorise quand même la nature et
valorise aussi l'amitié puisque pivoines
va devenir ami avec une petite fille de
la ville et que leur amitié va être très
forte ça va être une histoire de courage
d'amitié de protection de
l'environnement c'est pour ça que je
vous conseille ce roman pour les
collégiens voilà ça nous permet aussi de
nous rappeler que nous avons de la
chance de vivre encore dans un
environnement que ce sont les abeilles
qui nous offrent les fruits que nous
pouvons déguster via un chèque jouer
assez facilement qu'il vient de poésie
ça fait du bien par les temps qui
courent on parle tout d'abord de réseaux
sociaux si je vous dit greta tamba
forcément ça vous fait penser à ce
symbole de la jeunesse qui s'engage
depuis 2018
on entend peut-être moins parler de
quelque chose d'autre que vous avez
sélectionné pourtant tifosi et bien on
ignore que greta si elle est devenue une
icône en fait des jeunes pour la
protection de l'environnement c'est
aussi devenue une héroïne de la
littérature jeunesse il ya énormément de
livres en fête qui sont sorties qu'ils
l'apprennent comme héroïne
alors ce livre là et plutôt didactique
ce n'est pas un roman ni un album
s'appelle nous sommes tous greta des
idées pour changer le monde de valentina
gnl à emmanuel amara 10 et publié par
nathan est en fait d'abord ça vous
présente évidemment greta et ensuite par
petits chapitres sa aborde les grandes
thématiques en fait qui se posent au
niveau de la protection de
l'environnement donc à la fois qu'elles
sont deux modes de consommation qu'est
ce que la biodiversité ce que sont les
énergies fossiles et c'est très très
documenté alors il ya à la fois vous le
voyez des graphiques mais aussi et bien
des explications avec des chiffres
publiés par le giec
mais c'est à la fois très simple donc
c'est accessible à partir du collège et
vous voyez à ça fait référence à l'onu
tout un tas de chiffres c'est aussi très
bien illustré donc c'est agréable à lire
parce que c'est organisé par chapitre et
ça permet à tous de se dire mais qu'est
ce qu'on peut faire pour changer le
monde
il ya plein d'idées de petits gestes je
vous le conseille pour les collégiens il
je sais pas si on va changer le monde en
30 secondes en tout cas pour être
beaucoup plus concret vous avez un
dernier ouvrage un album celui là qui
est presque un mode d'emploi finalement
tiffen pour terminer oui alors le titre
c'est alto déchet zéro gachi ses 2o la
volt handicap tout cimme ce cas chez
casterman
et alors ça c'est vraiment le mode
d'emploi pour changer nos consommations
ça commence par nous expliquer pourquoi
nous sommes noyés sous les emballages et
bien notre passion du plastique est en
cause évidemment et puis ça donne plein
d'idées pour changer changer en fait nos
modes de consommation déjà on pourrait à
nouveau utiliser d'autres emballages des
emballages naturels comme les bananes
losier ou le verre et puis on pourrait
aussi et bien procédé différemment par
exemple se prêter les objets au lieu de
vouloir les posséder
comme ce livre là qui est vous voyez
plutôt un livre encyclopédique un qu'on
lit page à page qu'on feuillette et qui
pourrait trouver sa place et bien non
chaque dans des bibliothèques par
exemple scolaire où on pourrait
l'emprunter se prêter et découvrir tout
ce qu'on peut faire pour changer nos
comportements au quotidien par exemple
consommer du vrac les circuits courts
etc
vous voyez c'est très joliment illustré
j'ai adoré c'est à partir de 8 ans et je
vous le conseille
merci tiffen quelques idées à glisser
sous le sapin ça fait du bien de bon
matin et moi j'aime merci pour votre
joli sourire
tiphaine barnabé soigner la planète la
dernière abeille
nous sommes tous greta et alto déchets
c'était le tout dernier quand on vient
de découvrir avec vous à 0 gâchis n'y a
pas eu de gâchis ce matin et ça jamais